[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome once again to I'd like
to know to my right Pastor Daniel
Miranda to my left Pastor Stephen Bohr
we are here to answer your questions on
one of the programs that we really like
here at secret Sunset and some TV
because we get to study the word of God
which is something we love to do and we
get to answer your questions which is
something we also love to do because it
lets us know what's on your mind what's
on your heart as you watch programs from
time to time as you listen as we walk
together this road that leads to Glory
questions come up understandings must be
given and it is our privilege and
pleasure to give you that understanding
if an understanding can be found should
you like to get in on the fun Should you
like to be part of this program we
encourage you to contact us at TV at
some
tv.org that's TV at some
tv.org and as we always say if an answer
can be found from the word of God we
will try our very best under the Lord to
find that answer and get it to you
if you don't hear your question right
away please be patient we're we're
coming we're getting to it it takes a
little while the stack is impressive and
new questions come in every day I think
sometimes past that people think that
their question is the only question that
we do yeah and that is not so we get
many many questions
in English and Spanish and so these two
worthy men who are bilingual have to do
English programs and Spanish programs
also so their time is divided uh praise
the Lord not their loyalties but their
time is divided as they answer questions
in two languages so uh write your
questions and then sit back and enjoy
the program we will get to your
questions as soon as we possibly can
Pastor Daniel I'm going to ask you to
open up in prayer if you will and then
we'll get started okay let's bow heads
for prayer Heavenly Father we do not
dare to open your word without seeking
your guidance we know Lord that of
ourselves we cannot understand it
we pray Lord that you may give us wisdom
as we seek to answer these questions and
that they may be of great help for those
who are listening in the name of Jesus
we pray amen amen amen and amen we've
got a question that we have actually had
before and have wrestled with us a
little bit before this comes from Daniel
he says did dinosaurs exist before the
floods please help me I would like to
know well he would like to know so
if you go back into the archives We have
dealt with that question uh fairly
extensively uh the answer is yes by the
way but there's more than just that
explanation as far as dinosaurs existing
before the flood and why they did not
come through the flood why they were not
taken into the ark there is a number of
statements uh from the spirit of
Prophecy that give us understanding uh
about dinosaurs the size of men as
opposed to the size of dinosaurs and
just a number of things so there is a
fairly decent amount of information that
can be gleaned from the spirit of
Prophecy and if you go into the archives
you can find the program where we dealt
with Dinosaurs fairly extensively and
we'd like you to have that information
so do a little checking and you can get
the answer to your question might be a
good idea to mention the app that we
have Daniel could you say something
about the app so they know how they can
access that information so we have a
recent we have recently developed an app
where you can actually
go and see all the questions that we
have already answered for this program
it's just very easy you go download the
app is called samtv sum TV and then you
have to create an account this is all
for free and once you create your
account you can go to our program I'd
like to know and check all the programs
from the first program that was recorded
and there you will be able to read the
answers that the questions that have
been answered for each program so do
your research and not only that but you
will find also serious by Pastor Stephen
Bohr and others that are also there so
we highly encourage you to download our
app
to find amazing material there yeah if
you have the initial app the initial
some TV app that's not the one we're
talking about this is a fairly new app
the old map is not designed uh to give
you this information nor to give you
this ability to search but the new app
does and does so with Fair ease so uh
download it and then a whole new world
of research opens up to you and that's
why it was done so that you could have
ready access to this massive material
that has been gathered over the years uh
for your enrichment and your enjoyment
so do that and uh you'll be blessed all
right um let's see who's got the next
question is it you Pastor yes I have the
next question and this question comes
and I think we have already received
questions from him it's called em I
remember
we're trying to guess the name it only
says here em
and the question is who is the son of
hinom what does the what does that
relate to value of hinom and gehenna
well I think I did my research in the
Bible about the sons of hinom or hinom
we don't find specific information in
the Bible about who hinom was the first
time that there is a reference to hinom
is actually in the Book of Joshua
where we see that that Joshua is
describing the borders
of the land of Canaan and here in Joshua
15 verse 8 the Bible says and I'm
reading from the King James version and
the Border went up but by the Valley of
the son of hinom
and to the south side of the jebusite
the same is Jerusalem and the Border
went up to the top of the mountain that
lieth before the valley of hinom
Westward
which is at the end of the Valley of the
Giant's northward so it seems to me that
that name
belonged to DAL Valley already even
before Israel took possession of the
land this is the first incident that we
find in the Bible the first reference to
the valley of hinom
probably it refers to an individual with
that name probably and the valley was
given the name of that person although
we don't have a lot of information about
the person it's kind of like you we name
three ways and we name Bridges according
to previous presidents so you know
somebody I know the world isn't going to
last this long but supposedly a couple
hundred years from now when they see uh
George Bush Bridge they're going to say
where they get that name come from so
and so basically probably it's named the
Valley's named after an individual
now it was later
uh in the history of Israel this Valley
was the scene of a different evil
practices
for example the Hedonism offering the
sun's to Malik and later also became one
of the dumps the dump the dump city of
Jerusalem Jesus uses in the New
Testament as an illustration of the
final judgment yeah he uses that and
some people take that as referring to
Hell burning
Eternal burning hell because Jesus says
that the fire never quenches and the
worm Never Dies yes but actually Jesus
was referring to this specific place
where the garbage of the city was dump
yeah yes and if I was burning there all
the time all the time I was burning
there all the time so that's Mark Mark 9
verse 43 yeah yeah where the worm does
not die fire is not Prince I'm sure that
if you went to that landfill in Staten
Island
I'm not taking from somebody who has
great experience and who knows that land
you know every time I go by that
landfill in Staten Island the anfield
landfill for New York City yes I'm
amazed at the number of Seagulls yes and
birds that are there yes you know
praying on what's in that landfill but
I'm sure there's lots of worms there too
I would think I think so that's similar
to what was happening in the days of
Christ in the valley of hinnom it was a
garbage dump where they even through
corpses yes they didn't burn people
alive there as the parallel passage in
Matthew says but they they cast
carcasses in into hinom
yeah that that's the fresh kills the
landfill on Staten Island by the way
yeah which they say can be seen from
space it is so large oh wow it's quite
big but the the research I have it says
it's a historic Valley uh to the west
southwest of Jerusalem and of course
gehenna fire is always burning city dump
a place of refuge and and Christ used
that as a an object lesson dare we say
for uh what hell is all hell is all
about very good question yep and uh we
are thankful for it now we move into
let's see is it the biblical count of
Earth's creation
it's
um actually the one in Romans 14 is what
I have okay all right
is that the one you have Daniel
Cecilio
Sylvan Holland
I have Reynaldo Montano
okay well let's go to that one I have
another one before that but let's go to
that one
do you want to read that question yes
so we have here a question from Reynaldo
Montano and he says hello God bless you
this is my question
Ellen White said in many of her books
that Satan said in heaven that the law
of God could not be obeyed
is there a verse of the Bible where it
tells that Satan
said that the law could not be obeyed
well we do have verses in the Bible that
tell us that Satan was a law breaker
that we do uh first John chapter 3
is one example of that
of course sin is what transgression of
the law right yes so first John chapter
and we'll just read verse 4 and then
we'll read verse 8.
and uh First John 3 verse 4
says whoever commits sin also commits
lawlessness and sin is lawlessness King
James says transgression of the law and
then verse 8 it says he who senses of
the devil for the devil has sinned from
the beginning so he spent at the law
transgressor since the beginning
according to this and you know it says
in John 8 44 that he's a liar from the
beginning God shall not bear false
witness there's a Commandment that says
that so it's obviously he doesn't like
the law of God very much yes and I have
a way also to prove that for example
Pastor say I was going to say something
no I I had John 8 44. okay and the past
I still stole my thunder so it's quite
sorry
well the Bible says in Isaiah 14
that when Lucifer tried to
take God's Throne the Bible says here
that in verse 13 for you have said in
your heart I will Ascend into heaven I
will exalt my throne above the stars of
God I will also sit on the Mount of
congregation on the farthest sides of
the north I will Ascend above the
heights of the clouds I will be like the
most high it is interesting here that we
see the Throne of God and we also see
the mountain of the congregation and we
also see the sides of the North
now in in in psalm
and I believe this is Psalm 99
Psalm 99
actually 97 verse 2 we find a reference
to the foundation of God's Throne
because as Satan wanted to occupy God's
throne
here in Psalm 97 verse 2 the Bible says
clouds and darkness surround him
righteousness and Justice are the
foundation of his throne so when Satan
tried to occupy God's Throne according
to Isaiah 14
actually what he was fighting was the
foundation of God's Throne which is
which is righteousness and Justice now
we ask what is righteousness in Psalm
119 verse 172 my tongue shall speak of
thy words because all thy Commandments
are righteousness so the foundation of
God's Throne are the Commandments of God
and when Satan attacked God's throne and
he said I'm going to establish my own
Throne on the sides of the north what he
was saying actually is that he had a
better law he had better righteousness
he had better Justice instead of God's
justice and therefore or he wanted to
Institute a different kind of government
with this he's implying that God's law
cannot be kept and we have an
illustration of this in some countries
in the world in the last few decades you
know what is it that someone who
organizes a coup against the government
what is the first thing that that person
says so this President here he's not
administrating the laws the way it
should if you put me there things are
going to be a lot better you know and
you're going to be a lot Freer so so
what's what Lucifer wanted to do by
overthrowing God's Throne well it was a
coup and it was a military coup because
of Satan and his armies are fighting
against God and His armies so the first
thing that he attacked of course was
love God and Ezekiel chapter 28 and
verse 16
says by the abundance of your training
you became filled with violence within
and you sin and sin is the transgression
of the law of the law so uh basically uh
he sins from the beginning according to
First John chapter 3 verse 8. amen you
know it's it's interesting how
consistent Satan is in his tricks and in
his lies uh what comes to my mind is
when Absalom stood at the The City Gate
and and dissuaded the people against his
father David you know you know if If I
Were King
things would be different around here
you know
if I are running the show that we would
have a lot you know he's not doing his
job and it's the same thing that that
Satan did ah God's not yeah and it's
interesting when people on that story
when people came to the gate absolutely
was waiting there before they got to the
king yes and told them you're not going
to get Justice from the King right come
on you know if you would put me there
yeah then there would be Justice I would
do you justice and uh it was actually a
coup against David yes and we know how
that ended and so Satan works very
consistently he is a liar and we must
remember that that he's a liar from the
very beginning and he has not changed
and and will not change uh When sin is
done and Satan is done lying will be
done also we pray
alrighty uh good question and um
we are thankful for that the next
question is let's see Pastor you have
that one yes
um I hope it's in the same order that
you have but this one comes from Hans
Decker
is that correct
and the question is this I'd like to
know if there is a difference between
Fallen Angels and Demons the internet
has some weird explanations
okay that's the last place you want to
go for that understanding yeah the fact
is that the Bible tells us that the the
demons are Fallen Angels they are indeed
yeah any
um any biblical evidence of that
well
the the verse that comes to my mind is
um I believe is second Peter
actually doesn't use the word demons
but it does mention about the following
of of these of these angels
uh here II Peter chapter 2
uh and here we're going to read
verse
let's see here verse 4.
and I'm going to read verse 3 for the
context it says by covetousness they
will exploit you with deceptive words
so here this is talking about false
prophets and false teachers
for a long time their judgment has not
been idle and their destruction does not
Slumber then the verse 4 for if God did
not spur the angels that sinned by
casting down to Hell
and deliver them into chains of Darkness
to be reserved for judgment so here we
we we're told about angels who sinned
and were cast down to Hell or Tartarus
okay and and they were there we served
for for judgment uh now Jesus says that
he saw Satan falling down from heaven
and Satan is is an angel another another
word that is used for Satan is also
demon for example those who were
demon-possessed in Jesus's time
Jesus said that they had been captive by
Satan so Satan demon Angel fallen angels
all that is referring to the same thing
and there's another interesting detail
you know in Mark chapter 1
and verse 21-24
it says here that the evil spirits which
which would be the demons they knew who
Jesus was yes he came to his own
and his own knew him not but they the
but the demons knew who Jesus was why
because they had been acquainted with
them already in heaven let me just read
that then they went into Capernaum and
immediately on the Sabbath he entered
the synagogue and taught
and they were astonished at his teaching
for he taught them as one having
Authority and not as the scribes no
there was a man in their synagogue with
an unclean spirit
which is the same as a demon uh and he
cried out saying let us alone what have
we to do with you Jesus of Nazareth did
you come to destroy us I know who you
are the Holy One Of God so they knew who
Jesus was uh Satan knew who Jesus was
and of course all of the demon activity
in the days of Christ was was the
emissaries of Satan the angels of Satan
who were doing all the work yes
um
so anyway hopefully that answers the
question
and um well done
um I was just looking at something in
Luke 33 but it's basically the same the
same Luke 4 33 now understanding of
there's a man with and who had a split a
spirit of an unclean demon the Bible
says uh now in the synagogue there was a
man who had a spirit of an unclean demon
and he cried out cried with a loud voice
saying let us alone what do we have to
do with you Jesus of Nazareth so the
point is well taken that they knew who
they were dealing with they were
pre-acquaint acquainted with him this is
not a first time meeting they knew who
he was and they knew the power that he
had and they also knew what he came for
are you going to destroy us yes
yeah which which means they they
realized that he had the ability he had
he wished to absolutely to do it at that
time you bet right yeah very good very
good that's it let's look at our time
that's 622 left on the clock Daniel what
do we have
uh here we have um
well actually we don't have the name of
the person Let's see we have it at the
end uh
the end what the person calls himself
who is that guy okay
and the question is but in his email
address there's the word Oliver in the
middle so maybe we're talking Oliver
Oliver that must be his name yep
um it says when well in the title
is when does Sabbath start these days
eating of unclean needs and why has
Adventists do we have the Bread and Wine
four times a year and then he breaks
down his questions in more detail uh the
first question is what time does the
Sabbath begin and what scriptures
support that
well there's Mark chapter one being that
I'm already in box chapter one and verse
32 it tells us at evening when the sun
had set
they brought to him all who were sick
and those who were demon-possessed
so the Sabbath ends
when the sun sets and of course there's
the famous verse in Leviticus 23 32 from
Eve until Eve until you keep your
Sabbath so that tells us that the
Sabbath begins that evening when the sun
sets yeah we we have developed uh I
guess since the back of the days of the
Roman Empires this idea of starting the
middle of the night when everybody's
asleep but that was not biblical uh it
was from even to evening even in the
morning with the first day so you start
the evening on one day you go to the
evening or the next day and the new day
starts which actually is much more
natural than starting the day in the
middle of the night when everybody's
sleeping yeah it makes uh really uh
that's New Year's Eve yeah
or over there are several parts of that
question there was something else yeah
I'm going to add one more reference that
we find in Nehemiah chapter 13 verses 18
and 19. you know Nehemiah was rebuking
the people and the leaders because they
were allowing the time the people from
Tire oh I remember calm and sail on the
Sabbath day yes and here the Bible says
he is rebuking them and Nehemiah this is
Nehemiah speaking
your fathers do this
and did not our God bring all this
disaster on us and on this city yet you
bring added wrath from Israel by
profaning the Sabbath and then verse 19
says so it was at the Gates of Jerusalem
as it began to be dark before the
Sabbath that I commanded the gates to be
shot and church that they must not be
open till after the south then I posted
some of my servants at the gates so that
no burdens would be brought in on the
Sabbath day you know at the beginning of
the development of the Adventist
doctrines
um Joseph Bates
proposed that summer began at 6 pm and
for several years that's how our
Pioneers kept the Sabbath
until James White was not satisfied with
that and he asked Jay and Andrews to do
a thorough research on the issue of the
date or the time to begin the Sabbath
and and Jay and Andrews came to the
conclusion that Sabbath begins at uh
at sunset
and so James White was satisfied with
that conclusion and other delegates but
Joseph Bates and Ellen White were not
and Ellen White receives a vision from
God where God corrects her and tells her
basically that Joseph that Andrews was
right that's correct in regards to the
time beginning the Sabbath yeah and this
all harks back
to Genesis chapter 1 yes where the
evening comes before the morning each
day except the seventh day it says it
was the evening and the morning of the
first day evening morning of the second
day and so on uh if the day began in the
morning it would have said morning and
evening not evening and morning good
morning so this method of Sabbath
observance goes all the way back to
Creation
that is very consistent okay well done
gentlemen did we answer all the the
different parts of that question it
seems like there's well the the question
has
uh six parts that we might not be able
to answer in their cycles that we have
left but we'll continue Next program
answering this question very good very
good I again we want to encourage you to
um
send us your questions uh they don't all
have to be six part questions like this
one is but if they are several parts
we'll try to get to each part and uh
hopefully we have explained uh these
nuances in our faith and in our belief
systems uh to your satisfaction there is
an answer to be found in the word of God
and uh again we promise you to find that
answer and to give it to you the address
where you can send your questions TV at
sum s-u-m
sumtv.org that's TV at some
tv.org and we will study the word of God
and get to your questions just as soon
and as quickly and as thoroughly as we
possibly can well gentlemen our time has
fast slipped into
eternity allow me to our viewers to uh
commend you to Jesus Christ and in
closing to wish you God's grace God's
blessings God's grace and his truth as
you study the word of God and fortify
yourself for that day when Christ shall
come again God bless you one and all
we'll see you again soon bye-bye
[Music]
thank you